it's great to welcome to the program
today scott lynn who's the founder
and ceo of masterworks which we're going
to be talking about we're going to be
talking about
art and blue chip art fine art and and
so many different things scott it's
really great to have you on
thanks for having me so to start with i
i think
probably much of my audience understands
the idea
that uh there's sort of art that you
might grab
at a tag sale or at a booth at a
farmer's market
when they invite a local artist and then
there are
really expensive pieces of art there are
priceless pieces of art there are
high-end collectors
but talk a little bit first about the
the space you're operating
in what what sort of uh pieces we're
talking about
the value how these are transacted give
us like a sense of the space a little
bit
yeah so i guess when when you think
about the art market today um
i i would think about what we generally
refer to in the industry is just
fine art generally so that's art that's
sold by
by galleries um that represent artists
and that's that's
sold through through auction and if you
look at the the total size of the market
there's roughly 1.7 trillion dollars
um in in asset value and there's roughly
68 billion dollars in art that sells
every single year so it's this it's this
massive industry
um it's this massive industry that most
people just just don't understand that
well
and is the reason people don't
understand it because it's completely
inaccessible financially to most people
or because they're
it's actually deliberate in other words
there's there's somebody who benefits
from
lack of transparency in the space yeah
it's a good question so when you when
you think about that 68 billion dollars
in art that sells every single year
roughly two-thirds of that is by art
despite the top 100 artists
so those are artists like picasso et
cetera sort of household name artist
so those artists obviously are selling
today in the millions of dollars
and it really is inaccessible to most
people so if you you know if you think
about the very typical customer
in the in the art world today it's
usually an ultra wealthy person
um and sometimes families that have been
collecting for generations
so when we hear that a certain
piece by a top artist a top 100 artist
like you're talking about
was purchased 10 years ago for 80
million dollars and now it sold for 120
million dollars
what exactly justifies that increase
in price i mean is it that the market is
literally so small
that it's just fickle and if somebody
just happens to want it for 120
it now has gained 40 million is it more
directly connectable to
supply and demand and as some of these
works get older particularly from
artists who are no longer
alive there's just fewer of them in less
good condition
yeah it's it's there's two dynamics
really that impact pricing
um in the art market or that cause our
prices to go up over time
the first dynamic is just the growth of
the ultra wealthy sort of the top one
percent around the world
and regardless how you feel about that
that's a dynamic that is that is
happening
yes um and we do think that our prices
are correlated to that that the second
thing
which is interesting is we always get
this question
you know do do prices go up when an
artist dies
and the the short answer is yes but not
necessarily because
of the of the artist dying that that
event in itself doesn't really
drive prices up but what does happen is
the artist
naturally stops producing work so as
soon as the artist
stops producing work supply over time
starts shrinking because a lot of a lot
of collectors donate
donate works to museums or institutions
over time so you you know you look at an
artist like jackson pollock is my
favorite example i think
uh the drip paintings which a lot of
people are familiar with there's
something like 21 or 22 drip paintings
left in private collections today
all but a couple of those are not even
great paintings but they're still
selling for 30 million dollars just
because
that's that's all that's left there are
lots of stories and i've read some
interesting ones
about some of these um uh very
very uh desirable pieces of art being
purchased and then essentially taken out
of uh they're never seen again so to
speak they go into a private collection
sometimes even the buyer will keep it in
a strategically
selected country to avoid in some cases
certain taxes that may happen when they
when they may
transport the piece of art how do you
qualitatively evaluate that aspect of
this market
and the the sort of that that desire
that some have
to buy a piece and then it's essentially
taken out of public view
forever is that something you would call
a problem in this space
is it neither good nor bad how do you
evaluate it
yeah i mean i you know i think i think
it um
look we fundamentally masterworks we
believe in sort of
uh taking the paintings that our
investors own and displaying them in
public institutions
um over time uh that dynamic does
does occur and a lot of the people that
are taking works out of circulation are
people that are doing it for investment
um so i you know i i'm not sure
i guess if i if i would call it
necessarily a problem but i do think
there's
there's better ways to um to display
that work and kind of
manage it over time what do you think is
so i mean i'm using
language that implies you know sort of
like personal benefit but
what do you think is in it for a
collector to
buy a really expensive piece and then
immediately
loan it to a museum with no intention of
ever
taking it from the museum it's
essentially on like a permanent loan to
a museum
is it the desire to see their name there
as on
loan from joe schmo is it is it maybe a
financial
uh benefit and they don't really have an
interest in the piece of art itself like
what what's in the mind of some of those
collectors
yeah i mean a lot of that is just
philanthropic
um you know the vast majority of work
that the museum's received today is
donated by collectors
um there's there's a tax benefit but
most of most collectors that are
donating
at least at least high value works are
not not really doing it for any
financial reason
okay so as an investment one might
imagine
if they don't know that much about this
asset class
that because of the sort of limited
market
because some of these pieces are so
expensive particularly from the top 100
artists as you're talking about
that the return on such an asset class
would be either erratic or unpredictable
or whatever the case may be what what's
the truth about this as an investment
well if you if you look at those top 100
artists that we reference and you
compare that against the s
p over the past 20 years it's slightly
it's slightly outperformed the s p
so the the asset class um from what we
see
tends to perform better than public
equities in most cases
and it's it's really interesting if you
look at the individual artist market
level which is
which is how we tend to segment the
market there's certain artist markets
that are appreciating it above 30
20 so just like any other asset class
there's there's all
you know there's these different pockets
which are really interesting um
within the art market and i i think the
thing that's different about the art
market compared to
you know venture capital or private
equity is the art market today is still
relatively unsophisticated you know you
think about the size of venture private
equity it's a three and a half trillion
dollar asset class
but there's 6 000 firms that help people
or institutions allocate to that asset
class like in the art market
it's 1.7 trillion dollars but there's
there's really there's nobody that's
even securitized to painting
up until masterworks so it we just view
it as a lot of opportunity
to to generate returns simply because
there's not really that many
that many people focused on it is the is
the typical downside illiquidity i mean
the reason i ask is
in general uh if there is the potential
for a higher return there's something on
the other side of that either the money
is tied up for
a period of time i mean how how long can
i'm reading naked money now by charles
whelan
and he often will go to on the one hand
you have cash as the most
liquid asset because it's already cash
the furthest thing on the other side is
a really expensive piece of art which
is is even less less liquid than a home
because not everybody needs expensive
pieces of art
you know the home is likely to be
convertible to cash more quickly is that
what's on the other side of the
potentially higher returns
yes so maybe just to walk through that
kind of the life cycle of how we think
about investing in a painting so we
so we'll go out and we'll purchase a
painting usually between
one and ten million dollars um you know
by an artist like basquiat
um we then turn around and we sell
shares in that painting
um and then as you as you just mentioned
we'll hold the painting for a period of
time
usually we tell investors to think of
that between three and seven years
and then we'll eventually sell the
painting now we did just we did just
introduce
um secondary markets for investors in
the last six months
so we now have people trading chairs in
these paintings as well
so if an investor needs liquidity or
wants to get out before we eventually
sell the painting
they can simply sell their shares to
someone else in the trading platform so
pre-masterworks the illiquidity was the
downside
i think that's right yeah i i think
there's you know the obvious period to
entry for for most people is these
paintings cost millions of dollars
right so it's this asset class which
historically is appreciated
um and you know outperform public
equities but the only way you could
allocate to
it is if you have a million dollars to
buy painting so it it really was just
limited to the ultra wealthy
um so i think that's the biggest barrier
to entry and then and then i would agree
liquidity historically
was probably the second so now you're
sort of alluding to what masterworks
does so let's talk about that i mean
essentially what what you you're doing
is
you've created a way where you are
opening up the possibility
of investing in this asset class to
people who are not super high net worth
individuals
yeah and we do you know each of the
offerings that we do is actually filed
with the sec
so these are um are qualified public
offerings meaning anyone
anyone can invest so you don't have to
be an accredited investor um
it's really open to anyone how many
pieces of art does masterworks currently
have you know i think we're now in our
on our 22nd or 23rd painting
um i may have that wrong but but we're
doing a painting
um almost every week now so um so we're
quickly quickly rolling out offerings
uh back to back at this point and if
someone
says okay i want exposure to this asset
class
i can't buy an entire painting so i want
to use masterworks
talk to me a little bit about the
process how little can one invest what
is and i guess now this may be changing
as you add secondary market offerings
but
what you're saying think about it is
three to seven years is everybody
typically out when you sell the painting
or how does that all work
yeah so so the um so i guess the getting
started process is really simple you go
to the masterworks website
um www.messworks.io create an account
uh have a call with our our membership
team uh our membership team will will
talk to the investor about
how they're investing today talk to them
about risks on investing in art
decide what the right the right
allocation is for them
to the asset class and then really
talk to them about offerings that are on
the platform now what's coming up in the
future
and help them think about portfolio
construction within
within our it's very similar to how you
think about working with
an investment advisor for for equities
but we just do with art
are there rules of thumb that you think
are reasonable when it comes
to you know when bitcoin and crypto
started being a big thing
you would hear you know you don't really
want to have more than six percent of
assets and crypto because it's very
volatile or
you know you never want to have more
than 15 percent in cash these these are
rules of thumb it doesn't necessarily
mean that they're
they're universals but is there some
analogy to that
in the fine art space yeah we partnered
with uh with citigroup at the end of
2019 to do a correlation study on the
asset class which helps inform how to
think about
an allocation model we've never actually
built one ourselves but city
did build one and i believe they
concluded that
someone should allocate anywhere between
two to
eight percent and are depending on
their tolerance for for liquidity so
it's more of a liquidity question than a
risk question
it's more of a liquidity question than a
risk question it's really interesting if
you if you look at the asset class
um we we tend to to focus on what we
call loss rates like what is the the
probability of losing money
um in our and then we focus on if you do
lose money what's the magnitude of loss
and what you'll see generally is that
our from a losses perspective and from a
magnitude of loss perspective
performs much better than than public
equities
then oil then real estate um
other common asset classes and i guess
maybe that's not necessarily surprising
right like if you
if you have someone who's a collector
who buys a 10 million monet
their their interest in selling it for
less is just usually low they're already
wealthy
um but it does it does exhibit really
good quote unquote store of value
characteristics
one of the things that the art world is
notorious for is that there are often
not only can it take a while to sell a
painting
or a piece of art but there are often
high commissions that are paid
to auction houses um how does that
figure into
are you accounting for that when you
talk about the returns
yeah it's definitely i mean the the
transaction fees broadly defined in the
art market
um are huge i mean i think they go up
every year but i think now you know if
we
if we if you were if you were to go into
an auction house and purchase a 10
million dollar painting
you would pay something like an 18
commission
which is just insane right it's a 3.8
million dollar commission
yeah so one of the one of the great
things about working with with
masterworks is uh due to our
relationships with auction houses we're
able to negotiate those
away substantially um same thing if we
if we purchase privately so
you know we still pay commissions
sometimes they're two three four five
percent
um but they're not usually the the
standard commission rates
is there a defined line between
when art becomes an investment and when
it's not i mean so so it's like a
counter example
if you go to the local art show and buy
something that a local artist made
it seems that it's extremely unlikely
that any
aspect of that transaction is an
investment if you're talking about
picasso
you it clearly is potentially an
investment and it's in the space that
you're operating in
what's the line between those two
extremes
i mean it you know the the career of an
artist is a uh
it's a it's a challenging career right
like you know i just gave the stat where
roughly two-thirds of the total dollar
volume in the art market is from
100 artists mostly mostly deceased
right out of nine billion people that
have ever lived or whatever the number
is yeah
yeah so you think about you know all
these kids graduating every year every
year with mfa's it's a it's a really
hard career
you've got to really do it because
because you love it um so
the vast majority of artists that we
look at we don't consider
investment grade um and and that's
that's
you know even artists that are that are
culturally significant so for example
one of the things that we learned very
early on is that appreciation rates by
individual artists tend to follow
recency meaning if you invest in a
rembrandt today
rembrandt is just not that fashionable
so you won't lose money investing that
painting
but your investment will probably only
grow at one or two percent a year
maybe in context with inflation so so
in today's world we really focus on art
created after world war ii
and we tend to focus on artists that
have momentum we tend to focus on
artists that have
markets above 50 million dollars a year
um it's it's you know it's
very hard to to view sort of ten
thousand dollar paintings twenty
thousand dollar paintings
even in today's world hundred thousand
dollar paintings as as
investment grade because it's just too
unpredictable is there something about
the masterworks approach
that is almost like democratizing
access to the space in the sense that
with with fractional investment
you're you're opening this up to large
swaths of people that could never have
access otherwise
yeah i mean i i use that exact exact
word all the time
and i think what's really cool here is
right we we can take a painting that's a
culturally significant painting
we can have a couple thousand people
essentially purchase the painting
and then we can take the painting to an
institution or a museum hanging out on
the wall
and it doesn't go out of circulation so
it's a it's a really nice way for people
to gain exposure to the asset class
and also for artists to continue
exhibiting their work publicly
super interesting we've been speaking
with scott lynn who's the founder and
ceo of masterworks about which you can
learn more at
masterworks.io scott i really appreciate
your time
thanks david